هذا وهنا الرئيس الروسي الذيربوتين الرئيس
الصيني
بمناسبه اعاده انتخابه رئيسا للصين في
برقيه ارسلها الى رئيس الصين قال الرئيس
الروسي ان بلاده تقدر عاليا مساهمه الشيجم
بينك في تعزيز
الشراكه والتفاعل الاستراتيجي بين البلدين
كما اعرب بوتين عن ثقته بان البلدين
سيضمنان بناء تعاون مثمر في مختلف
المجالات بالعمل معا وسيواصلان تنسيق
العمل المشترك بشان اهم القضايا المطروحه
على جدول الاعمال الاقليمي والدولي
من بيجينا مراسله الجزيره شيماء جوي تنضم
الينا ولايه ثالثه امر غير معهود وغير
مسبوق منذ مده طويله في الصين كيف تبدو
تحديات هذه الولايه وكيف مر اليها
نعم زيدنا عابدين بالفعل هو امر غير معهود
وغير مسبوق في الصين الرئيس شيجين به هو
الرئيس السابع الجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
لكن لم يكن قبله اي رئيس تولى منصب
الرئاسه لاكثر من ولايتين متتاليتين ماء
ساعدني على ان يصنع هذا الفارق في تاريخ
الصين هو التعديل الدستوري كما ذكرت قبل
قليل الذي تم عام 2018 والذي استطاع
بموجبه ان يلغي محدوديه فتره الرئاسه بحسب
الدستور الصيني الدستور الحزب الشيوعي
الصيني الحاكم الذي كان محددا بفترتين
رئاسيتين فقط كل فتره تمتد لخمس سنوات
وبعدها تم هذا التعديل والموافقه عليه من
قبل مجلس نواب الشعب الصيني بالتالي منذ
عام 2018 زين العابدين يمكن القول بان كل
التوقعات كانت تشير الى ان شجيم فتح امام
نفسه باب الرئاسه مدى الحياه اضافه الى
ذلك في اكتوبر الماضي اجتماعات الحزب
الشيوعي الصيني الحاكم وبعد ولايه ثالثه
ايضا استطعش الحصول عليها امينا عاما
للحزب الشيوعيه الصيني بالتالي كانت كل
التوقعات والترجيحات انذاك تشير الى ان
اجتماعات مجلس نواب الشعب
المبرمجه في مارس اذار من عام 2023 سوف
تكون نتيجتها ولايه رئاسيه ثالثه للرئيس
في البالغ من العمر تسعه وستين عاما اليوم
هو اقوى من اي وقت مضى اكثر من السنوات
العشر الماضيه يملك بين يديه سلطه قويه
تخوله لان يكون الرجل
الاوحد في الصين الذي يملك اعلى سلطه وذلك
بترائسه
للحزب الشيوعي الصناعي الحاكم وايضا
بتراوسه للبلاد وكذلك
بشغله منصب منصب الرئيس الرئيس اللجنه
المركزيه العسكريه الصينيه والتي تعادل
القائد الاعلى للقوات المس الصينيه
بالتالي الرئيس جيمبي اليوم بعد تعزيز
مكانته داخل الحزب في اكتوبر الماضي
وتعزيز مكانته رئيسا للبلاد لولايه ثالثه
نتحدث عن صلاحيات الكبيره غير معهوده
يملكها خاصا وانه ايضا قام بالغاء كل
معارضيه حتى من من المحامين بحسب بعض
المصادر المطلعه بعض المحامين الصينيين
ورجال القانون الذين كانوا يدعون وكانوا
اصواتا تدعو الى الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان
هذا الملف شديد الحساسيه داخل الصين قام
رئيس جيم بتصفيه هذه الاصوات وكذلك ايضا
بتصفيه المعارضه في الاقاليم مثل هونج
كونج عندما نتحدث عن احتجاجات عام 2019
التي كانت تنادي بي مزيد من الاستقلاليه
لهون كونغ عن البر الرئيسي للصين وايضا
مزيد من الاستقلاليه للحكومه المركزي
المحليه هناك عن الحكومه المركزيه في
بيجين تعزيز الديمقراطيه تعزيز الحريات
هذه الاحتجاجات المليونيه التي خرجت في
هون قام ايضا الرئيس السجن بهيم بقوه
باخمادها ومنذ ذلك الوقت قام ايضا بتعزيز
حكومه محليه في هونغ كونغ تتبع في الولاء
للحكومه المركزيه في بيجين وبالتالي يمكن
القول زين العابدين بان السنوات الخامسه
المقبله سوف تشهد تتمه لسياسه سياسات
شجنبي بصفته في البلاد
مراسله الجزيره من بيجين شكرا جزيلا لك